o
hoje eu queria compartilhar com vocês um
pouquinho do meu sonho eo meu sonho é
bastante simples
eu queria que todas as pessoas do mundo
tivessem acesso a uma vida saudável
somos 7 bilhões de pessoas no mundo e
dar sete bilhões de pessoas no mundo foi
um relato agora da organização mundial
da saúde dizendo que 2,5 bilhões de
pessoas não têm acesso a banheiro isso o
banheiro 35 por cento da população
mundial não tem banheiro em sua casa ou
não têm acesso à saúde saneamento básico
agora vocês se perguntem se essas
pessoas não têm acesso a banheiro
elas vão ter acesso a um exame para
detectar dengue tuberculose hepatite
câncer não né
agora se eu perguntar pra vocês
quantos celulares existe hoje no mundo
quanto vocês me diriam 1 bilhão de
celulares cinco bilhões de celulares de
acordo com a organização internacional
de telecomunicações vamos chegar a 7
bilhões de celulares no final desse ano
o que fez a onu fazer uma declaração de
que temos mais pessoas com acesso a
celular do que acontece ao banheiro
isso é bom mas tenho até um lado da
tecnologia a gente tem tecnologia
agora o importante é como fazer essa
tecnologia mudar o mundo
imaginem vocês vocês estiverem saindo de
casa para ir trabalhar meio adoentado
hoje em dia ninguém tem a a idéia de
ficar em casa contra a doença é preciso
trabalhar e quando tivesse chegando em
casa chegando ao trabalho desculpa
travasse a porta a porta para essa
mensagem volte para casa pois você está
doente
de preferência já mandando e mail o
chefe avisando né ou se por acaso vocês
vão ao banheiro e um banheiro faz uma
margem da sua urina e mandar mensagem
para você você precisa beber mais água
conservar a outra
coisas do cotidiano você tá indo viajar
no aeroporto aqueles procedimentos de
embarque e aqueles detectores de metal
uma mensagem pra você prezado passageiro
o senhor não poderá embarcar pois está
infectado por um vírus parece
brincadeira né
isso seria um mundo com os biossensores
você não poderia entrar no seu trabalho
para tentar evitar que a infecção de
gripe
no momento todo mundo paga ao mesmo
tempo né a idéia do banheiro faria com
que vocês mudassem de hábitos para
melhorar a saúde
às vezes só um simples copo de água ou
mudar um pouco a alimentação já evita
alguma doença
a idéia do aeroporto poderia fazer com t
doenças como é bom
esses biossensores ele já existem já
estão por aí eu penso eu sou bastante
conhecido
vocês com certeza já viram ou ouviram
falar
só não devem saber que é um biossensor é
esse aqui é um medidor de glicose aquele
aparelhinho que o pessoal que tem
diabetes costumam andar para monitorar a
glicose é o meu senso
ele funciona bem simples você coloca uma
gota de sangue numa tirinha coloca tinha
um dispositivo ele visa a quantidade de
glicose que tem um sonho
microscopicamente funcionar da seguinte
maneira o sangue tem várias moléculas de
glicose e aquela tinha tem um elemento
biológico capaz de reconhecer essa
glicose
então quando você coloca aquela gota de
sangue na feirinha agricoffee vai se
ligar a essas enzimas e o dispositivo
vai contar essas ligações dizendo quanto
que a pessoa tem de idosas ela pode por
exemplo tomar um sorvete eu tenho que
comer uma salada naquele dia
agora imagine essa tecnologia simples
portátil barata para detectar outros
tipos de doenças
é isso que a gente vem trabalhando há
cinco anos mais ou menos eu trabalho no
laboratório de biossensores do livro ela
na universidade federal de pernambuco
a nossa ideia é desenvolver esses
dispositivos para outros tipos de doença
e aí quando comecei o meu doutorado a
idéia era que tudo isso que a gente vai
detectar neste momento em que caminhava
muito com
minha amiga roberta que também faz
doutorado lá ea idéia dela é entender um
pouquinho de quais lhes causam câncer de
mama
e aí eu pude entender então um pouquinho
mais no mundo do câncer que é um mundo
extremamente dolorido
eu posso apostar com vocês que a maioria
de vocês conhecem alguém que teve câncer
ou até mesmo já teve um caso de câncer
na família é uma doença extremamente
devastadora não só devastadora para o
paciente mas também devastadora para a
família e o pior dessa doença que você
não pode combater um vírus não bactéria
que você pode lutar contra o câncer uma
doença do corpo próprio corpo as células
perdem a noção de se multiplicar
continuam crescendo até formar um tecido
inútil
então melhor forma de combater essa
doença é fazer um diagnóstico precoce e
vendo a história da roberta trabalhando
com câncer de mama eu entendi um
pouquinho isso não sei se vocês sabem
mas pra esse ano são previstos 57 mil
mortes por câncer de mama no brasil
no mundo esse número sobe para mais de
meio milhão de mulheres
é um número absurdo pra fazer o
diagnóstico desse câncer como é feito
hoje
a maioria feita por um exame chamado
mamografia que a mulher coloca os em uma
macro é um exame de raio x e essa
máquina aperta aperta aperta quando a
mulher não aguenta mais ela para manter
a atenção pra fazer um exame de raio x
precisamos dar para as mulheres assim
como o exame de câncer de próstata mas
para estar para os homens extremamente
confortável mas quando a gente fala de
saúde
o importante não é o conforto é a saúde
então vamos seguir continuam a fazer
esses exames
entretanto uma pesquisa da fundação
nacional do câncer dos estados unidos
disse que esse exame para detectar
câncer de mama tem um índice de 20% de
falso negativos quer dizer que cada 100
mulheres que vão fazer o exame 20 e
volta para casa achando que não têm
câncer
daquelas mais de meio milhão de mulheres
talvez 100 mil morte pudesse ter sido
evitadas
é um número grande muito disso vem que a
mamografia só consegue detectar e se
cansa quando ele já está acima de meio
milímetro mas o câncer já existe lá nada
disso
isso é um problema da técnica a gente
aqui no brasil ainda tem outro problema
que é um problema do sistema público de
saúde
hoje tem filas para marcar exames fila
para a marca médico fila pra voltar pra
entregar os exames
hoje a gente pode demorar até seis meses
para fazer um exame no sistema público
de saúde
agora seis meses para pessoas que têm
câncer é uma eternidade
então a idéia foi voltei pra começar com
roberta
vamos tentar fazer então biossensor para
diagnosticar esta doença como ela
funcionaria existe não é com a chamada
micro a reunião ela está sendo bastante
estudada no mundo os cientistas porque
ela é liberada pelas células quando
ocorre o processo de câncer
então a gente teve a idéia e vai a gente
fazer aquela tirinhas para detectar
glicose
vamos fazer essa carinha para detectar
microrregião e assim detectar o câncer
muito antes daquele meio milímetro da
mamografia
então a gente tinha idéia vamos lá
conversar com o nosso orientador para
tentar fazer o projeto e foi a primeira
vez que esse projeto
ele foi engavetado disse pra gente que
não tem dinheiro pra fazer esse projeto
então a gente tem vontade e sabia como
fazer trilhas técnicas não tinham
dinheiro para fazer o projeto
mas aprendi na vida que a gente não
desiste nunca né
e aí nesse momento da vida é o césar já
que recife é um instituto de pesquisa em
tecnologia da informação e robótica
procurou meu orientador com a vontade de
participar de uma competição
internacional em biologia sintética lá
no haiti
como ele não tinha nenhum normal em
biologia procurar o orientador e aí foi
um momento vamos desengavetar o projeto
vamos mostrar o xá reza vamos fazer o
projeto todo mundo gostou
temos agora o dinheiro montamos então
uma equipe uma equipe de corajosos
alunos de graduação e alunos de pós
graduação
dispostos a tentar fazer esse sonho se
tornar realidade
só que agora a gente com dinheiro com a
idéia
contudo também tinha um prazo à
competição começava o dia 30 de outubro
ele estava no começo de abril
então a gente tem que correr ea idéia é
fazer o que um sistema seguro e sensível
que nem o medidor de glicose está indo
louca que nenhum paciente tivesse que
sofrer aquele incômodo da mamografia
portátil porque muitos e muitas cidades
do brasil não tem acesso a todo o
sistema diagnóstico e os pacientes têm
que vir do interior para a cidade da
maia trofa para fazer os exames
então a idéia que fosse uma coisa
portátil e rápido para que quando o
paciente chegasse naquele exame já
conseguir o resultado no mesmo dia
como é que ele funcionaria simples para
o paciente ser um exame sangue
a idéia é construir um robô que pudesse
separar esse microfone a do sangue que é
diferente da glicose ele fica dentro da
sala e esse robô já colocaria a amostra
no biossensor ea gente colocava o
biossensor do leitor
exatamente como o bebedor lhe causa só
que para detectar uma reunião
então nos últimos sete meses nós viemos
trabalhando para criar esse sistema e aí
foram várias e várias noites no
laboratório sábado self de sábado à
noite self de domingo e madrugada para
as meninas e os meninos não muito fã de
céu fiz ea partir de lá no finalzinho já
de setembro essa competição nós
conseguimos terminar esse projeto
a gente conseguiu construir um protótipo
do robô e conseguiu terminar o
biossensor para detectar um mico rn há
ainda gente conseguiu afastar esse
biossensor com amostras de pacientes do
hospital barão de lucena então as
pacientes que eram positivas porque não
cederam positiva o nosso de um sensor
que acho que eram negativa para o câncer
deram negativos do biossensor também
então a gente conseguiu provar que ele
realmente estava funcionando nesse
momento eu me lembrei de uma história eu
não comentei com vocês ainda mais sobre
o mel
e aí o bem antes de entrar na
universidade
ainda na dúvida de qual profissão ia me
levar pra ser cientista
eu cheguei é minha mãe virou pra mim
pois assim filha é por favor
tenta construir o exame preventivo
melhor do que esse de câncer que se dói
muito não quer fazer quando terminei o
biossensor como eu tenho voltei pra casa
da irmã vista direitinho vai falar no
futuro que se viu assessor já está a
caminho em firme e forte
a gente já estava com tudo pronto para
viajar fomos embora os estados unidos
e aí quando a gente chegou no espaço na
competição a primeira sensação que a
gente teve foi a sensação que todo ser
humano tem chamada medo medo porque a
gente deu de encontro com mais de 244
times do mundo inteiro
você já dá encontrar hoje ainda vou dar
uma dica melhorar
ora gente aí levantando a mão esse é o
nosso pequeno time e chegou nós que nos
amedronta dados pra melhorar dentro de
um encontro com outros times do brasil
tenha mais três times no brasil nós
somos o primeiro do nordeste e um deles
chegou pra gente fez esse pm tem
melhorou o time forte chegamos até aqui
construímos o equipamento vamos até o
fim e aí a gente descobriu que a maioria
das apresentações aconteciam
simultaneamente era 19 auditórios ao
mesmo tempo e que as universidades
grandes lotavam os auditórios
então cheguei pro meu amigo que aprontar
comigo lucas disse lucas se prepara que
nossa vitória vai está vazio
a gente vem de recife de universidade
que quase ninguém conhece quando não
está fazendo tabu
a gente não tem a mesma quantidade de
dinheiro que off rafa e mate tem e
tamanho do time a gente é muito
pequenininho
então se prepara para não se frustrar na
hora da apresentação
mas por incrível que pareça nós damos
encontro com a vitória lá paulo gente em
pé
gente de todos os países protejam
a gente quando a gente tem na nossa
apresentação muitos deles vieram
conversar e como esse projeto é
importante como esse projeto era bom
inclusive um dos times da califórnia
veio conversar com a gente dizendo que
queria muito que a gente ganhar essa
competição internacional
pra gente foi ótimo foi muito
gratificante no dia da premiação nós
conseguimos ser classificados como
medalha de prata em uma das categorias
naquele momento pra gente pode dizer que
tudo valeu a pena
a universidade que ganhou foi justamente
aquela da califórnia que disse que
queria que a gente ganhasse
então pra gente vai conseguindo novos
ganhado neste momento a gente pode ver
que valeu a pena
mas valeu a pena só porque a gente
conseguiu se classificar com alguma
medalha de prata
valeu a pena porque foi lá que ele forme
queria que a gente ganhar
valeu a pena porque aquele meu sonho não
era mais o meu sonho que mais pessoas
trabalhando isso as pessoas estão
acreditando nesse sonho não é uma
posição minha mais quantas pessoas agora
acreditam que isso pode mudar que a
gente pode ter um diagnóstico mais
barato mais seguro mais sensível
agora ele muitos câncer de pele
a lista é imensa e nós não vamos parar
a ideia é construir um sistema rápido
para todos eles
a gente não pode evitar a fila do sus
não temos muito o que fazer com a espera
dos exames mas a gente pode sim
trabalhar para um diagnóstico através de
um sensor mais rápido que possa ajudar
salva vidas
muito obrigada